the bachelorette is curious about anal
and that is
uh an instagram video that i came across
as i was looking on her instagram now i
want to show you
something uh that's quite interesting
the reason i know about this
um is this the current bachelorette
katie thurston uh took a picture of
what just a crazy transition out there
yeah we were just giving up for these
you know political parties i think it
makes perfect sense by giving it up
we're finding her breaking point
i'm on instagram and jared freed comic
because we've had on the f
on the podcast down in miami our boy
jared he does these amazing like rants
about the bachelorette
he also does this like live uh show
about the bachelorette after each
episode
and on his youtube and he took a picture
with katie
the current bachelorette after one of
his shows in tacoma i guess she's from
washington she came out to the show
so i i look and i'm scrolling through
her instagram and um i
uh [ __ ] i'll just be completely
honest i noticed that she had more uh
lips now and uh you know so i was like
let me go to that back of her instagram
at the end
and see if i can find a video and
from like way back in the day and see if
she didn't have as much
movement and see exactly because it's
harder you know so
if there's no filter you could see the
video blah blah so i go back i just pick
a random video there's no
title for this video or anything you can
see right now there's no title it's just
a random [ __ ] video
that i just pick i press play out
press play is this what you do on the
toilet yeah maybe this is probably what
i do okay here we go
do i start with this question i'm gonna
start with this question have you ever
[ __ ] on a dick i have not
but my friend uh [ __ ] on her husband's
dick during anal and now i'm horrified
and i just don't know where she went
wrong
like ladies how are you preparing
yourself to avoid
that scenario like if i have coffee in
the morning
is like anal like off the table for the
day if i have
taco bell is it off the table for a week
like what if you haven't had your daily
poop yet
or do you do some special like prep work
up there
i don't know i don't know it's for
educational purposes only because i
cannot be the only one
inquiring i just know
i'm [ __ ] scared and i need some
advice like i hear it's a game changer
but i am not getting in the arena until
i have some details
queen queen
she's she earned it this is a great
video it's great it's funny
i mean she's got some punch lines in it
yeah it's good it's very good
it's just still up on her instagram you
know that the bachelor looked through
her instagram and told her to scrub
every single [ __ ] picture that wasn't
uh on brand whatever
she was already on the bachelor by the
time this video happened i think yes
she's like
bruh she what she came in with a dildo
first episode of the bachelor she
brought she was like the dillian
she brought the [ __ ] dilly out
she went from dildo girl to the
bachelorette
that's usually how it is if you have a
dildo with you all the time you're a
[ __ ] bachelorette but
she might be the most appropriate thing
what's the biggest thing at a
bachelorette party fake dicks everywhere
wow
that's the bachelorette all brands the
bachelorette brand they know what
they're doing
but the point is that's a wild girl out
there talking about [ __ ] on dicks
still up on
instagram so glad i found this and what
drew you to this mizzou because like you
shared this on your instagram i shared
it on my instagram
um i shared all my instagram stories
like the bachelor
is about that business i mean i just
thought it was interesting
looking at him trying to find the words
why i
yeah she's on an abc show
it shows on abc on prime time i'm about
to go home after this episode i'm gonna
watch it with my girl the whole time i'm
gonna look at her like
she takes dicks in her [ __ ] ass
she's curious she said it's a game
changer she wants a game change
yeah she did hear it's a game changer
she wants her [ __ ] split and not one of
those guys
on their introductions brought that up
they ain't doing no research
they didn't do the research they're
bringing a [ __ ] ball pit they're
doing all this other stuff man the cat
man kind of well how the cat man do it
cats lick their ass
cats lick their ass but they shove
nothing up there yeah yeah you know what
i mean
none of them light work say what looking
is that's light work
dude how did child's play how did a
black guy that's on the show
not like put up his his brown fist
and what let's see where you go keep
going
i'm just saying he's like i i would like
to
continue for this to be brown yeah he
did go where i thought he was gonna go
he's not gonna go there it wasn't there
oh [ __ ]
dude i thought it was kind of close i
was just thinking in the moment here
dude
it's called improv okay yeah jeez yes
and al you gotta yes and
we gotta go with it go back to the
bathroom this girl takes dicks in her
[ __ ] cake
and her what i'm saying i don't know
what's happening bro
i'm losing it dude she tasted she's
[ __ ] in her ass guys
no but she wants she wants she doesn't
get [ __ ] curious but
one of the guys on that show is gonna
have to deliver dick and [ __ ]
butthole oh
fantasy sweets fantasy sweets we're
gonna we're
anyway i'm very i'm very proud that i
stumbled upon this thing now good for
her
i liked her midway through this video i
was like you know what this girl's
that's a keeper she should be the
bachelorette she's got to be the
bachelorette how to listen i'll be
honest with you and i'm going to be
honest with you
i'm pretty sure that this is going to be
a news story that's popular now
and i just want the credit for starting
it kfc
did his one minute man about it now i
think it's gonna you know it's gonna
start to blow up because why would it
not be a big story the [ __ ] abc's
bachelorette
takes it in the ass yeah whole or wants
to
once it takes it's almost more exciting
which is why is it so awesome isn't that
something i like
why is that so awesome i too because
here's the thing a roll do they do the
roses for the bachelorette i forget i
don't know bachelor's degrees
roses there's no men don't give a [ __ ]
about a rose we don't but if that rose
comes
with anal that's the rose i want that's
a rose that you want that's a stinky
rose i want this rose has thorns
yeah ribbed for no one's pleasure
but this is this is this is not news no
it's something it's kind of news
oh it's news that [ __ ] is news i don't
know you grew up in a different era i
feel like okay like i don't know
like i grew up i didn't want to lose
their virginity gets [ __ ] in the ass
yeah exactly if you grow up catholic you
get [ __ ] in the ass a lot
so this doesn't say weird to me no but
like who is talking i went to school
with like
professors that would talk about like
anal sex like
what yeah like catholic school yeah like
yeah
that's how they warm them up
[Laughter]
wait what the [ __ ] happens your g-spots
in your [ __ ] or whatever lies gay
guys tell straight dudes
that's in your [ __ ] you actually
believe that [ __ ] i'm good without
i come just fine without that go on
there were like girls
at my school that would do like uh it
was like they would do like they would
have a booth outside like the library
and they'd do like a
like an educational day where they would
teach like bondage
and like they would like to show you how
to tie knots and [ __ ] like what school
is this
it's a high school is it my college oh
you're college that's different yeah
yeah kids are weird in college but like
i thought this was high school no no
only fans university i don't know i'm
just not stunned the girl that's on tv
is like talking about anal
really yeah name another famous girl is
on tv talking about anal
i don't know i also don't watch an atv
so i'm like i hate this guy man
i'm not surprised a girl is on tv
talking about anal
yeah and then you just said i don't
watch tv yeah
so what would surprise you or what are
the surprises you don't know anything
about tv but i feel like my perception
of media is like
podcasts and [ __ ] it's call her daddy
yeah exactly those are professional
horror talkers okay for a living they
have to talk about being
hoarse yeah so of course they're gonna
talk about anal and sucking dicks and
all that kind of that's the podcast an
hour a week you gotta do it you're gonna
get together
pretty quickly you gotta have some [ __ ]
to talk about this is about finding love
this show it's about finding love and
embarking on a journey and finding your
person never is it i'm going to find my
person to [ __ ] my ass
that's a good ass point but now we have
to look at it like that she's looking
for the perfect guy to [ __ ] her ass
that's something that she's considering
[ __ ] ass good
you know what i mean she's looking a
massive story and i don't like that
you're trying to actually
try to belittle the story name one of
the persons to get [ __ ] on tv even
the ones that get [ __ ] regularly
won't even admit it
anderson cooper just became gay colton
was a bachelor coulter was a bachelor
level
he too probably has this pose he
probably liked it so i'm gonna go see if
colton liked this post on katie thurston
you know what lebron's talking about
taco tuesday
what go
you know what i mean that could be a
precursor that could be a precursor two
decades from now we found out lebron
don't do anal on tuesdays cause that's
taco tuesday that's his night off
katie thurston said no taco bell that
week yeah i'm just trying to say this is
a massive story in the bachelor
bachelorette world
girls are getting piped in their butts
in their butts dude them turd cutters
bro
are taking [ __ ]
it's true and that is something that
should be spoken about on the flager 2
podcast
100 it is weird i will say because i
don't know any other announcement
you don't know any other bachelorette
that would do that they would take dick
and butt that would talk about it oh
they would talk about it that's our
whole point
mark but like i'm saying in media though
i'm like
i don't know like girls just be talking
about yeah but the whole point is just a
bachelor bachelorette
into your point which we made five
minutes ago they don't talk about this
all i'm saying is this is gonna be a
national story and they're gonna get
crazy ratings and we're not gonna make
any money off
the [ __ ] story get your credit dog we
broke the [ __ ] story that's your
credit bruh can you imagine that bro
can you imagine that that nobody else
finds all the [ __ ] losers watching
the bachelor doing all this [ __ ] you
find every offensive thing anybody's
ever said
[ __ ] at a party that was once racist
or something that's a news story
she's talking about dick and butt that's
all and you and you don't even care just
a little dick and butt fun dude
[ __ ] pushed in do you know what i'm
saying
but [ __ ] push in right
come on bro yo come on there's got to be
someone on that show
tyler got to come out and say yo i'm
pushing too
you